software unification so that I no longer
care what computing device i pick up
whether it's a laptop or a desktop
whether it's one I own or one in a
public place whether it has a small
screen or a large screen I sit down
identify myself I tune in my information
world I get it in the same way on a no
screen computer in a car uniform access
across all platforms computers
telephones to my entire information life
it's easy to achieve in hardware they're
hard software issues but they should
have been solved 15 years ago
so long when the other side of the fence
of if I were to invest in a in a new
company I would invest in some of the
companies that are working on so-called
digital furnaces in five years everybody
throws out all his CDs and DVDs there
are larger mp3 players home stereo
systems and TV these systems are
integrated and this is a billion
multi-billion dollar transition as
things stand it will be Sony and Google
toshiba a few with very large companies
doing it and they won't they won't do it
badly but they won't do it well I would
invest in in one of the small companies
that has imaginative instead of recycled
ideas as to how to make that transition
you